so exciting to be sitting here with one
of the funniest people I know Ben
Schwartz Parks and Rec House of Lies
rejected oh and a true improviser and
gentleman
so happy to be next to Pete Holmes
youporn yuge is um what's your other big
one next video next video we used to
improvise together back in the day we
did improvise I say I think this is to
your credit you're the only guy you and
Thomas Middleditch with the only two
that could not that it's because I'm bad
Oh keep going it sounded like I was
giving myself a compliment right well
we'll hear Risa but it takes a talented
improviser to deal with life eyes with a
big baby that was one of the last time
that improvise is that sure it isn't
Umbro it's not sure I know that they are
I consider it a gateway drug to real
comic okay I'm insulted go with that and
I don't like it
Dulli JK you want to play the psychic in
by the way I am a little bit psychic I
could do it for real yeah me too okay
Ben Schwartz here I'm gonna zap someone
your head off yeah yeah I'm gonna really
do this you're gonna guess will not be a
bit I'm gonna really zap you something
real quick I'm just thinking of an atom
you have to write it down all right Dola
please look the other way let's really
do this I wouldn't ever I'm not even
listening to how many strokes you're
doing hold up hold up hold up ah don't
wanna know I wanna know Gerber okay okay
okay okay okay ready I'm going to
actually you have zap and animal into
your brain
I'm gonna clear my head it's there I see
it oh right I put it inside your brain I
could see it there okay chicken flip
that card and read on the top zebra but
on the top go your self